l'heure de pointe d'un vendredi de la
fin ou dans la deuxième plus grande
ville de suède
ils sont près deux millions à vivre dans
la région de göteborg
c'est beaucoup moins de résidents car
montréal mais la population ici et quand
même habitué aux bouchons sauf que
depuis 2013
ils ont fondu de 12% depuis en fait que
la ville instaurer une taxe sur la
congestion routière à göteborg 37 postes
de contrôle entoure le centre ville les
plaques des voitures y sont prises en
photo et on envoie une facture mensuelle
à leurs propriétaires confiance et jonas
marrane travail pour transporter helsinn
l'agencé suédoise des transports qui
administre ce péage et celui de
stockholm ceinture et le centre ville
dit il était la meilleure façon d'avoir
un péage avec de l'impact
c'est une taxe sur la congestion
si on veut vraiment la réduire au centre
ville alors on a besoin de ces postes de
contrôle il dresse un bilan plutôt
positif après deux ans même si leur
espérait encore moins de voitures sur
les routes ifs
à göteborg les tarifs changent selon
leur passer un poste de péage entre 7 et
8 heures le matin par exemple coûte 22
couronnes suédoises soit 4 dollars 40
la facture est de 3 $ 30 entre 8 et 9 et
2 e de l'art 80 après 9 heures les
passages sont gratuits le choix et la
fin de semaine
près de 130 millions de dollars sont
ainsi amassé chaque année selon le plan
suédois les sommes recueillies sont
investis pour une raison bien précise
ça doit servir à améliorer les
infrastructures de göteborg dit jonas
marrane piste de vélo nouveau pont
stationnement incitatif et c'est
énormément de voitures en ville toujours
stéphane andreessen habite dans l'est de
la ville
lui et sa conjointe doivent
régulièrement prendre leur voiture pour
aller travailler au centre ville
inévitablement ils franchissent alors un
péage
stéphane nous a montré sa facture des
mois d'hiver
ça nous coupe les deux semblent dollars
canadiens par mois et donc pour nous on
a pris l'habitude de le payer
on n'a pas le choix et on a les moyens
de le payer mais il est pour l'idée d'un
péage afin de réduire la pollution mais
trouve que le périmètre payant est trop
grand je sais pour un péage vraiment
pour aller dans le centre ville pour
aller dans le coeur de la ville
mais aujourd'hui on a un péage aussi
pour sortir de la ville pour passer à
côté de la ville
donc je trouve que le système il est mal
faire
l'an dernier lors d'un référendum 56 %
des habitants de göteborg dont stéphane
ont dit non à la poursuite du péage les
élus ont quand même décidé de continuer
espérant que la population changera
d'idée quand le nouveau plan
d'infrastructure projeté avec ses
revenus sera réalisé pratique
un vrai que le transport en commun est
plus populaire à göteborg depuis le
péage
la première année le nombre d'usagers
sur tout le territoire a augmenté de 10%
le vice président de la société de
transport local précise que les services
avaient été améliorés en vue du péage
il n'avait pas le choix pour réussir la
transition mais somme toute presque
trois ans après la taxe de congestion
ceux qui gèrent la ville de göteborg
sont satisfaits ici le matin c'était
pare-choc contre pare-choc avant le
péage
aujourd'hui dit-il il n'ya presque plus
de circulation
en fait la ville calcul qui lie à 16 %
moins de voitures maintenant dans les
rues du centre ville et aussi 5% moins
de co2 certains commerçants ont quand
même souffert admet le porte parole
l'argent des commerçants vieille - des
automobilistes est davantage des piétons
et des cyclistes
au total dit il les sommes dépensées au
centre ville sont à peu près les mêmes
l' agence suédoise des transports et
mais quand même un avertissement sur ce
type de péage si votre centre ville est
animée et que vous créiez que cela lui
nuise pensez peut-être à d'autres
solutions
d'autant que ce système coûte assez cher
à exploiter prévient jonas marrane
il lance tout de même cet avis comme une
évidence
le principe de l'utilisateur payeur est
aujourd'hui la meilleure façon de
financer les immenses besoins en
infrastructures et ce même dans un état
providence comme la suède
de quoi faire réfléchir montréal dans
son deal 1 sur les péages